all right neuro now that he's released
his new book with this tension-filled
cover pose Donald Trump must show us the
rest of the photo
knurl this man must be congratulated for
taking a stand in life some are called
to fight injustice others to defend
their country but a rare few are called
to make sure Caitlyn Jenner pees
standing up like he was born to now
whatever your name is sir I'm gonna
guess Dale it is my honor to present you
with the first inaugural urinal cake of
freedom award
knurled jeb Bush's campaign has to lose
the exclamation point
sorry Jeb exclamation points are for
closers here's your new campaign sign
near Olsen's Hollywood keeps making
movies about flawed but brilliant chefs
mountain climbing and Steve Jobs even
though no one goes to see them the
combine if it to one huge bomb called
eat it Steve Jobs restaurant on Mount
Everest starring an actor with a
production company a tiny English
actress half his age on a trout the
rules stop criticizing Mick Jagger's
ex-wife Jerry Hall for dating Rupert
Murdoch after all she's already made a
grown man cry now it's time to make a
dead man come
and finally new rule if neurosurgeon dr.
ben Carson really believes that somebody
with zero governing experience is
qualified to be President he must first
let someone with zero medical training
operate on his brain and given some of
the [ __ ] that comes out of his mouth I
think someone already has now if you're
following the presidential race
you know the 2015 has been the year of
the amateur if there's one thing
Republican voters can agree on
it's that the less the head of our
government knows about government the
better John Kasich is one of the few
adults in the field and he's trying to
buck this trend with his catchy slogan
Kasich I know how a bill becomes a law
but that's not what GOP voters won
anymore
experience the knowing things
Republicans avoid that stuff like a gay
son and that explains their two leading
candidates captain carnival barker and
sleeping the crazy pants
like many of you I've spent the past few
months thinking you can either want
Trump to be leader of the free world or
I can take you seriously but it can't be
both and ben Carson who says that the
Ayatollah Khomeni
and Vladimir Putin went to college
together which no one can even find a
source for except perhaps ambien
he's now the front-runner of course he
is because 85% of Iowa Republicans said
they'd find the total lack of government
experience to be his biggest selling
point but if their kid needed brain
surgery would they say forget ben Carson
he's a brain surgery insider where else
in life does anyone ever apply this
thinking when their toilet is broken do
they say get me anybody but a plumber
the shit's about to back up in here what
we need is an outsider so
it's this kind of thinking or the lack
of it that has inspired me to change my
view on an important aspect of American
elections I used to say that our
elections went on far too long but you
know what no Americans are dumb they
need extra time I used to think we
should do it like the British we're an
election takes five weeks or France
where the official length of the
campaign is two weeks I've been to
friends takes that long to get a waiter
to notice you and these are people who
will spend three days shopping for a
cheese that goes with pears their idea
of a fast food is a snail when they cook
Joan of Arc she was still pink in the
middle
Oh too soon for Jonah bar yeah it was
1413 wand you but look
we're not them we're not the French
we're not the British we're Americans
and we're far too dim and distracted to
responsibly make a choice in just weeks
or even months
we're like Lamar Odom at a whorehouse we
don't even have sex the first couple of
days that's just for letting the drugs
kick in if our election season was only
two months long Trump would have won
already in a landslide but time time is
our greatest ally against idiot
candidates already you're seeing people
tiring of Trump because he has three
pieces of stick upgrade Mexico's
laughing at us constipated toddler face
you